good morning and welcome to reviving the
Constitution the first ever Hillsdale
College Town Hall live from Chantilly
Virginia just outside of Washington DC
this event is sponsored by hills dales
Allen P Kirby jr. center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
established in 2008 the Kirby Center
teaches and promotes the principles and
practices of American constitutionalism
in the nation's capital and throughout
the nation I'm David Bob director of the
Kirby Center it's my pleasure this
morning to welcome all of you and to
lead our first morning's presentation
today more than 33,000 people from all
50 states joined together to consider
how we as citizens can revive the
Constitution of the United States of
America from Pella Iowa to Silicon
Valley California from Arizona to Ohio
to watch from Washington State to
Washington DC citizens are standing up
for the Constitution of the United
States
well maybe not enough yet in Washington
DC but thanks to citizen interest at
least they're starting to hear more
about the Constitution in the halls of
Congress and throughout the nation's
capital it was a interesting thing
wasn't it in the August Town Hall's
to see that it was not so much the
elected representatives that cited the
Constitution first but rather citizens
like all of you standing there holding a
document that has meant so much to so
many Americans throughout the years what
then is the Constitution the great
abolitionist Frederick Douglas asked in
1860 here I'm quoting from a speech that
he gave it is no vague indefinite
floating unsubstantial ideals something
colored according to any man's fancy now
a weasel now a whale and now nothing the
American Constitution is a written
instrument full and complete in itself
no court in America no Congress no
president can add a single word thereto
or take a single word therefrom it is a
great national enactment done by the
people
and can only be altered amended or added
to by the people end quote
Frederick Douglass spoke on the campus
of Hillsdale College in 1863 just three
weeks after the Emancipation
Proclamation came into effect our
College was founded by abolitionists who
like Douglass believed that the only
path to ending slavery was by standing
Foursquare on the principles of the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution during the Civil War hills
dales campus emptied out as some 500
young men fought for the Union in fact
from its 1844 founding Hill cells
consistently fought especially for three
things equality liberty and independence
in its commitment to equality Hillsdale
is the first institution of higher
learning founded anywhere in the world
with an express commitment to impartial
e-except all people men and women
regardless of their color
Hillsdale is similarly committed to
Liberty for we believe that a dedication
to the liberal arts yields liberty of
the highest order
the liberal arts the ancients knew and
we believed yet today helped to make
free individuals as hills dales founders
expressed it in the college's articles
of association they were quote grateful
to God for the inestimable blessings
resulting from the prevalence of civil
and religious liberty and intelligent
piety in the land those founders of the
college believed that quote the
diffusion of sound learning is essential
to the perpetuity of those blessings
this diffusion of sound learning
requires a certain kind of independence
independence of mind certainly but also
as Hillsdale College has discovered
independence from the interference of
the federal government to that end the
college does not accept any aid direct
or indirect from any financial aid from
the from the federal government this
comes not from an anarchical streak or
an aversion to proper accountability but
rather from the knowledge the dependence
upon federal taxpayer dollars means
subjection to federal rules and
Galatians that stifle the equality and
Liberty the college has stood for since
its inception a college that welcomed
Frederick Douglass when very few would
does not need agents of the federal
government dictating its curriculum and
culture free from any financial bail-out
from either state or federal sources
Hillsdale College sets its own course
Hill sales founders and the founders of
the country knew that the teaching and
learning of Liberty is required of
Americans if we are to enjoy the
blessings of liberty our rights are not
self-executing nor are they guaranteed
to endure they must be defended that's
why we gather here today before we begin
our first session in which I'll outline
America's foundational principles I'd
like to begin with a few program notes
throughout today's event which will
include five presentations we'll leave
about half the time for conversation
about the Constitution it's a town hall
this conversation will be driven by your
questions for those of you who are
watching from home you'll find directly
below the video player a link that you
can click on to ask any questions you
may also simply type an email to Kirby
Center at Hillsdale edu that spelled ki
RBY Center at Hillsdale edu when you ask
a question either online or in person
we'd ask that you identify yourself by
your first name and also tell us where
you're from we got a wonderful note from
a gentleman who asked us if this program
was also going to be available on DVD
Eddy from Woolwich Maine dials in online
but he works three jobs and he said that
he wasn't going to have time this
morning to join us live we will make
this presentation available for for a
good long time to come on the same
website and also we'll make it available
via TV via DVD for your questions we ask
that you keep those brief so that we may
address as many as possible
now if you might just have quick
reference to your schedule I want to
make a just a quick run-through of what
we're going to be covering today kind of
preview of what content we're going to
be into
pating throughout the day this morning
we're going to examine the principles
the rock on which America is founded and
then with dr. Matt Spaulding who directs
the Center for American Studies at the
Heritage Foundation and who has a new
book out we still hold these truths it's
a book that goes through systematically
and explains what these truths are and
why they are still not only relevant but
vital to the preservation of American
liberty Matt is going to talk about the
Constitution
what's the plain meaning of that the
plain written meaning what Frederick
Douglass was getting at in that
quotation that I started with then we'll
hear from dr. paul moreno a
constitutional historian at Hillsdale
College dr. Moreno will speak to
questions of the Constitution and the
Civil War what did Abraham Lincoln stand
for what was his role in preserving the
Union will then break for lunch during
lunch those of you who are watching from
home will have the treat of seeing a
speech that Mark Steyn gave it has the
simple title that especially those of
you who from the Granite State will
recognize Live Free or Die Mark Steyn
was on hills dales campus gave this talk
and believe March of 2009 you'll also
watch a video about Hillsdale College
that tells you more about the school
after lunch then we'll turn to the
progressives Constitution you know it
was a hundred years ago that the
progressives really came into their
their full flower and dr. post read Oh
dr. RJ post read Oh who is a Hillsdale
College political scientist and who just
has a new book out that focuses on the
writings the thought of the progressives
he spent particular time and attention
on the thought of Woodrow Wilson and
will address what is progressivism and
what are the what's the legacy of the
progressives today then we're really
pleased to welcome the president of
Hillsdale College dr. Larry Arne he's
going to address the question that I'm
sure all of you have in mind even now as
we speak and that is what do we do what
should we do
what can American citizens do to learn
to study and
know those things that allow us to
defend the liberties on which America
was founded that's our day we look
forward to to the program we're going to
dive right into to our first session and
let me just start by by calling
attention to some uniquenesses about
America in the next few minutes I'm
going to discuss three uniquenesses and
seven principles the first uniqueness of
America is that we have a birthday not
many nations as old as we do have such a
thing it's impossible to identify the
precise beginning of China or the
inception of Egypt we celebrate our
nation's birth as independence day we
came about as a result of a revolution
second then America is a revolutionary
idea John Adams was asked in 1819 by a
gentleman named Hezekiah Niles with the
Patriots of 1776 the men who fought in
the Revolutionary War falling daily
disappearing from the American scene
Hezekiah Niles wanted to know what was
the American Revolution really about
John Adams took great care in responding
and he summarized it this way quote the
radical change in the principles
opinions sentiments and affections of
the people was the real American
Revolution now for those of you who have
watched David McCullough's splendid HBO
miniseries on John Adams you know that
it was not he that was known so much as
being radical why did he use that word
then radical well radical Adams knew
being a classicist and a man of letters
comes from the Latin word that takes us
back to the root
he pushes us back then to the root of
things the radical change in the
principal's opinion sentiments of
affections of the people was the real
American Revolution Adam set says but
it's not radical in the sense that we
know that word today because the
American revolutionaries didn't wish to
change human nature they didn't wish to
throw off our religious underpinnings
they didn't even wish to do away
altogether at all with our British
patrimony but they did wish to become
one independent people separating
themselves from the British and in so
doing and this is the third uniqueness
our revolution resulted in
constitutionalism not many revolutions
do imagine for an example a college
student unpacking after the summer break
lovingly taking out their possessions a
banner of Che Guevara and putting it on
their wall right what that commemorates
the revolutions of the twentieth century
is something radically different than
the revolution that Americans fought and
won
whereas communist revolutions throughout
the 20th century sought to transform
human nature the American
revolutionaries knew that human nature
remains constant throughout the ages it
does not change that takes us then to
the first of our seven principles the
first principle is human nature now it's
kind of a funny place to start isn't it
because normally we don't think in our
political discourse about human nature a
whole lot but in fact for the founders
it was the decisive point of departure
as James Madison wrote in The Federalist
which was after all a series of op-eds
done in New York State defending were
really arguing that the Constitution
ought to be ratified that it ought to be
approved by the states Madison wrote
this but what does government itself but
the
greatest of all reflections on human
nature but what is government itself but
the greatest of all human but the
greatest of all reflections on human
nature he goes on to discuss the fact
that human beings are are not angels at
Hillsdale we have a course on the US
Constitution
every student all 1,350 students at the
college take that course as part of a
core curriculum that comes on top of
courses on the great books and English
literature and also then on two
semesters worth of history so the
students are understanding and and we
hope able to articulate then the
principles of the Declaration in the
Constitution but occasionally and this
has happened I think only twice there's
a funny thing that happens and that is
that phrase that Madison uses we asked
them to write or at least in my classes
I've asked Hillsdale students to write
an essay on what it means for men not to
be angels and occasionally we get a
variation on that theme men are not
angles that's a little different story
but men are not angels what does that
mean it means that that we're not
perfect right
we're not perfectible even human beings
are not perfectible the founders believe
despite this even as flawed creatures we
are capable of self-government
this was the founders contention as
Madison says in another one of those
Federalist Papers quote as there is a
degree of depravity in mankind which
requires a certain degree of
circumspection and distrust so there are
other qualities in human nature which
justify a certain portion of esteem and
confidence Republican government small
our republican government that is
representative government presupposes
the existence of these qualities in a
higher degree than any other form right
Republican government in other words in
which the people rule endure ectly
through their representatives but
nonetheless in which the people are
sovereign ultimately requires high
things of them sometimes the founders
are dismissed as as as individuals who
believe that human beings were not
capable of much that in fact what was
needed was a very controlling system
that would that would keep the the
wealthy the elite
the aristocrats in power but in fact
when you look at it as Madison contends
in this Federalist it took a lot of
confidence in human beings didn't it
just enough confidence to say that we
are capable of self-government but you
create government in such a way that
human beings and their proclivities
towards problematic behavior towards
greed towards rapaciousness towards even
to rent tyranny that those tendencies
can be controlled but then the really
tricky thing the most difficult thing is
to make sure that the government that
you set up can itself be controlled
right because the people who govern are
no different than those who are governed
their people they are subject to the
same nature as human beings what's the
alternative the alternative is to
believe that human beings are basically
good and that human nature is plastic
kind of like silly putty able to be
molded and shaped by the state or other
forces this is the progressive view as
we'll discuss later today
this view entails the possibility of
perfection it supposes that politics is
the means for perfecting people it
dictates then that the state gets
involved in that process of perfection
and it always fails for human beings
while capable of self-government are
incapable of infinite malleability
it's those revolutionaries of the 20th
century that supposed you could create a
new soviet man impervious to the idea of
human nature they believed that he could
be mold at any which way and human
beings broke more than 100 million of
them souls extinguished in the course of
the the 20th century at the hands of
communists the American Revolution and
the American revolutionaries view of
human nature is diametrically opposed to
that view
the second principle then of the
American Founding is natural law the
Declaration of Independence appeals to
the laws of nature and of nature's God
to justify the American cause of
independence
for those of you who are in studio if
you might have reference to your pocket
declaration and constitution he'll sell
college prints and makes these available
to people to date I think we've given
out over a million of them the
declaration makes an argument that today
Americans aren't quite as familiar with
as we used to be there are four
references to the divine in the
Declaration of Independence
two of them were inserted by Thomas
Jefferson in his original draft which he
didn't think by the way needed any
amendments but amended they did just a
little bit there were a couple of
amendments added that there were two
more references to God added and a few
other tweaks and and things done to the
Declaration of Independence but the 30
or 33 year-old Jefferson had had a
brilliant draft and was a craftsman of
the highest order
for references to God very briefly let's
go through them and ask what do they
what do they say well that first
references is in the first paragraph the
first paragraph of the Declaration
announces what the purpose of that
document is when in the course of human
events it becomes necessary for one
people to dissolve the political bands
which have connected them with another
and to assume among the powers of the
earth the separate and equal station to
which the laws of nature and of nature's
God entitle them a decent respect to the
opinions of mankind requires that they
should declare the causes which impel
them to the separation the first
reference to God then comes in that
curious phrase the laws of nature and of
nature's God the second reference then
is to the creator it is from the Creator
that human beings have rights and that
comes in the next sentence in the
Declaration of Independence the most
famous perhaps of all of them we hold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created equal that they are
endowed by their creator with certain
unalienable rights that among these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness so you have the laws of nature
and of nature's God and the Creator God
and if you drop back to the last
paragraph you find the other two
references God is referred to also as
the supreme judge of the universe the
supreme judge of the universe right and
then the final reference in the
Declaration of Independence is to divine
providence
now the Declaration of Independence
makes an argument the argument comes in
particular complaints against the king
it's saying of that king that he takes
the legislative power that he takes the
executive power that he takes the
judicial power and that he ERA gates
unto himself all three of those decisive
powers the Declaration of Independence
in Deitz the king by saying the prince
has become a tyrant the complaint is not
just against King George the third
though really because it's saying that
no human being would be capable of
holding all three of those powers only
God only the divine could handle that
kind of responsibility right and God
wishes for us to be ruled not directly
not in a theocratic theocratic form of
government but rather in a new form of
government and that the American
Founding came to that realization that
there república to be based upon natural
rights and upon natural law so the bill
of particulars those complaints against
the king that long list which they
complain about various offenses against
their liberties is backed up by this
kind of political theology these
references to God only God can handle
that kind of responsibility
no human can you can see in that then
the rationale for the separation of
powers right separate the powers so that
no one branch of government has all of
the authority
you know natural law is something that
is very often confusing to people
because it would be supposed that you
have to be of a particular faith or that
you would have to even be a Christian to
believe it in fact it's not the case
natural law is available to human beings
through reason it does it's not a sort
of a guide of here's what you should do
in a particular case or circumstance but
natural law indicates simply that there
is a foundation a basis for moral right
and moral wrong out of then those first
two principles the idea of Nate human
nature and natural law then comes the
third natural rights individuals are
endowed by their creator government does
not grant the rights that exist because
of our nat national condition as human
beings these natural rights are our most
precious possession let me quote
Alexander Hamilton he said this at the
time of the American Founding quote the
sacred rights of mankind are not to be
rummaged for among old parchments or
musty records they are written as with
the Sun beam in the whole volume of
human nature by the hand of divinity
itself they can never be erased or
obscured by mortal power that's the idea
of an alien ability right life liberty
property or in Jefferson's locution life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness you
know I remember as a as a kid seeing
something that some of you may have seen
actually on TV and others of you on DVD
now Schoolhouse Rock remember that I'm
just a bill I'm just an ordinary bill
this was a means rather a paltry one at
communicating civics lessons to Saturday
morning cartoon Watchers well the one on
the Declaration of Independence had at
the point when they're talking about
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness they showed a picture it's a
picture of a obviously a patriot an
American patriot and what he's doing is
he's chasing after a woman and she's
running from him and he's just not quite
able to grab her the pursuit right
that's what they were trying to show now
that's a really strange idea and it gets
it
completely wrong because the pursuit of
happiness was not just do your own thing
do whatever you think is right but
actually it's synonymous with virtue if
you read Aristotle and Jefferson says
that when he came up with the
Declaration of Independence his
inspiration was not something that he
just conjured up but rather it was
Aristotle Cicero Sidney John Locke if
you read those individuals those
political philosophers you see that to
be happy is to be virtuous to be
virtuous is to be happy you can't have
happiness in other words simply by some
hedonistic pursuit or some pursuit of
money but rather there has to be an
ultimate end it has to be directed your
pursuits as human beings have to be
directed towards the right things James
Madison and property said this he wrote
a little piece it's in your reader and
and it's a it's an op-ed written in 1792
bears the title simply of property as
the man is said to have a right to his
property he may be equally said to have
a property in his rights in other words
we think of property as stuff material
possessions but it's a lot more than
that in fact for Madison it is what we
own a materially our rights our most
precious possession are our rights the
goal of good government is the
protection of property the fourth
principle then is consent good
government can rule only with the
consent of the governed as the
Declaration tells us were citizens not
subjects you know it's sometimes thought
that the the the the break from Great
Britain that America affected was not
really that great that we were just kind
of continuing something rather than
actually breaking away and I would argue
that in fact we were breaking away in
one particularly decisive way and that's
the way that we understand rights in
the under the crown one could enjoy a
certain measure of religious liberty but
it was always understood more in terms
of toleration right
you're a subject you're not a citizen
that can assert by right of your being a
human being a right to religious liberty
it's a very different conception of
things because once you have a right by
nature that means that that's a right
applicable anywhere it doesn't matter
where you are those are what we call
today human rights but perhaps a better
way of thinking of them because it
points us back to the natural law is
natural rights the consent of the
governed is a pivotal principle for the
American founders it leads us then to an
understanding of the fifth principle
limited government this is an important
one because I think in an era of
political unrest in an era in which
we're trying to sort out as Americans
what role should the government have in
our lives it's very important to
recognize that the American founders did
not believe that the federal government
even should be weak because it must be
powerful in fact to do the things that
it must do those things that it's
charged to do particularly in article 1
section 8 of the Constitution government
must be limited in purpose then but
powerful in protecting people's rights
we don't want weak government after all
that's one of the things that the
founders and Matt Spaulding will address
more of this in his his presentation
this morning the founders were concerned
because under the Articles in Federation
there was a very weak government there
was no chief executive there was no
ability to tax at all there was no court
system to speak of that was a sort of
independent judiciary right these are
all innovations of the Constitution and
Madison Hamilton and Jay writing in the
Federalist and the others other framers
of the Constitution knew that they had
to avoid the example of many of the
states which themselves like the federal
government under the Articles of
Confederation were anemic they were far
too weak I often asked my students for
those of them that grew up in small town
they know that you can have a tyranny at
the local level right the American
Founding was very much about empowering
states and also local communities that's
where self-government was going to be
best lodged but it also established the
federal government that had particular
purposes and it had to be powerful in
being able to execute those purposes
right we want a president who can
operate with dispatch and energy you
need energy in the executive limited
government then is the fifth principle
we'll wrap up very briefly briefly with
two more responsible constitutionalism
the government is responsible to the
people not for them the government is
responsible to the people not for them
this takes us into those things that
they taught usually for most Americans
are where the really boring part of
civics begins right the separation of
powers and federalism and checks and
balances what Publius called in the
Federalist auxilary precautions but
while most of our high school textbooks
do a really lousy job of presenting
those things they're vitally important
to maintaining Republican government we
talked a little bit about the rationale
behind the separation of powers
federalism something that's almost
entirely forgotten today right that
understanding that it's not the federal
government's role to do so many of the
things that it does today this all leads
to the seventh principle self government
self government is the soul of good
government Americans James Madison wrote
rests all our political experiments on
the capacity of mankind for
self-government and as George Washington
said quote the preservation of the
sacred fire of liberty and the destiny
of the Republican model of government
are justly considered as deeply perhaps
as finely staked on the experiment
entrusted to the hands of the American
people an experiment
we think of experiment today in a very
different way you know Washington in his
correspondence which was voluminous
wrote very very often about the millions
yet unborn we have a tendency to think
very much in inevitability terms when we
think of history right we know how the
story ended
but for Washington for Madison and for
the other framers of the Constitution
for the founding fathers they didn't
they were uncertain - in fact even as
they signed that document on September
17 1787 as they sent it off to the
States wondering if what they had
crafted would even work wondering
furthermore would it be enacted and
wondering still more what would future
generations do with it
that's what they're thinking about when
they think of experiment as we'll see as
the day goes on and in future sessions
as part of our Constitution Town Hall
the progressives had a very different
understanding of experiment for they
thought of America is a very different
thing they saw the Declaration for
example as outmoded kind of like if any
of you had shown up today in a
tri-corner hat or came in and we were
listening to Fife and drum music right
it seems out of place I want to refer
just to one more document and then I'll
look forward to taking any questions
that you that you might have
fast forward to Franklin Delano
Roosevelt his 1944 State of the Union
address he refers to all of these
documents that we've just looked at the
declaration in the Constitution he
refers to the founding of America and he
said at this time in our nation's
history in 1944 on the cusp of winning
the war but still mired in the Great
Depression coming out of it a little bit
we'll hear a little bit more about about
that in our later sessions as well but
wondering are the rights that are in our
Constitution are they enough do we need
something more necessitous men are not
free men FDR said and while the first
bill of right
was okay for the framers and that time
we today need something different we
need something new he said of those
rights in the first Bill of Rights they
were our rights to life and liberty the
wall street journal editors the next day
after FDR gave this speech said that's a
curious use of the verb were don't you
mean they are our rights to life and
liberty in other words the first Bill of
Rights is still fully in effect those
natural rights don't go according to era
they don't come and go that's the very
idea of the fixity of human nature the
fixity of rights nothing from time to
time changes whether or not they in fact
exist governments even can come and go
and natural rights in Durer FDR says
what we need in addition then to that
old outmoded notion of rights is a new
one and he lists a bunch of them and
they should be very familiar to our ears
because they're part and parcel of our
political discourse today and in fact
they're part and parcel of a good chunk
of of the political platforms of really
both parties at least when you look to
what has happened in effect over the
last decade the right to a job the right
to earn enough to provide adequate food
and clothing and recreation the right of
every farmer to get a return on his
products a free trade the right of every
family to have a home the right to
medical care right this is in 1944 the
right to adequate protection from
economic fears the right to a good
education all of these spells security
FDR says life liberty the pursuit of
happiness and security
he amends the Declaration of
Independence bringing it up to date the
question I put before students who take
a course in in Washington DC as part of
our Washington Hillsdale internship
program is to compare Madison's piece on
property
and to stack up its argument for
government's role with that of Franklin
Delano Roosevelt's and the progressives
which one presents a foundation that
actually will support our edifice is
there attention there it seems obvious
in fact that there is attention which
foundation is more firm I'll end there
and invite your questions thank you very
much for your attention can line up
along the the sides of the room here and
we'll start with a a question from
online
our first question is from Jen in
Spokane Washington I'll just read it
here it seems that the more handouts you
give to people the harder it is to take
them away I guess government handouts
how can we get back to this radical
understanding of human nature natural
law and limited government we've just
seen so many government programs with
lasting consequences that it seems we'll
never be able to fully be a nation of
self-governing people I feel like I
sound cranky for saying this but am i
right well it's it's it's a it's a
question that that I think we're going
to spend a lot of time reflecting on
today it's a question that without
punting completely to dr. Arnn in our
fifth and final session he's going to
charge us with the the question okay so
we live in this thing that is sort of a
legacy of the progressives right what
you might call the administrative state
where you have government encroaching on
every aspect of your life a very
different world from that of the
founders what do you do what are your
duties anymore the rights don't change
but duties might it is very hard to take
handouts away from people and it seems
that what happened with the with FDR's
second Bill of Rights is that it was
never formally a proposed as part of our
Constitution right none of those things
are formally part of the the the the
Constitution of the United States but
they're part of our informal
understanding right if you were to do
this sort of political equivalent of
jaywalking and ask people let me read
you a list of Rights and you tell me
whether in the Constitution or not I
fear that a lot of people would say of
these rights yes they are it's because a
lot of our political leaders talk as if
they are in fact what you see also is
internationally FDR's Bill of Rights is
the basis for a lot of others countries
constitutions if you print out for
example the the list of Rights from the
European Union Charter of Fundamental
Rights it runs to it I think some 20
pages in Bagdad at the largest
university there 70,000 students once
they jettisoned the course on Baath
Party ideology they had to figure out
well what do we teach students now and
it's
what they chose us to teach from the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
and the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights was formulated in 1948 as part of
the United Nations conference and as
part of that formulation they said one
thing that we're going to have to do in
coming together to figure out a new
conception of Rights is forget about the
question where do they come from that's
off the table that's a pretty big
question though to leave off the table
so the questions to me seems to be that
if we're going to talk about all of
these handouts and and the kind of
government programs that breed a kind of
dependency rather than independence that
we have to go to the crux of the matter
and that's to talk about where the
rights come from if government can can
grant you a right of course they can
also take it away and the question is if
I have a right to a home who has the
right to pay for it the problem comes of
course in the taught as has been
chronicled by a number of individuals
some of the members of Congress there
reaches a certain point when people
become so dependent that it's very
difficult to take those things away
right and that's the place we are now I
believe because it's not just corporate
welfare though that exists in huge
quantities sort of crony capitalism and
it's not just welfare for those who are
poor we spent five trillion dollars on
the war on poverty but now the question
is for those that we call the middle
class are they going to give up their
government goodies that's the real
question we'll take a question now from
our audience sir
FDR propounded how did they allow those
to become an effect constitutional law
to be supported by the redistribution of
property property as reflected in the
Madisonian view how did the courts allow
this to come to pass well it's a good
question I think that you're right to
point to the fact that a lot of this has
been affected by a kind of judicial
revolution right a judicial action it's
not something that you can you can point
to just one or two court cases but what
you can see is an evolution that would
say even more and more the idea of
natural rights is completely irrelevant
to our understanding of politics and
political economy in America right so
once as a judge if you take away the
sort of natural rights framework what
are you left with you're left with just
then positive law the legal training for
most of our judges in this country and
most of our attorneys shifted quite
dramatically with the Progressive Era
what we came to do is we studied very
different documents very different
thinkers rather than looking to the
common law and to natural law thinkers
we began to look to different legal
traditions and we looked to especially
some German thinkers who had a very
different understanding of what a
constitution ought to be Woodrow Wilson
for example gives us the idea of the
living Constitution all right a living
political constitution he said that the
founders were all really subject the
founders were all subject to an old
understanding they were Newtonian what
we have to be is Darwinian and we have
to understand that the law changes it
evolves things become different right so
your legal framework changes quite
dramatically and then what what happens
quite quickly is that you have the
ratification of these new these new
ideas of rights and really by dictate by
edict the court says it shall simply be
so
and then what do you have in future
generations of law students you have
them reading court cases right just
Court decisions after Court decisions
without repairing to the standards and
the fundamental principles right and if
you just keep reading that then stack up
a bunch of court cases that start off on
the wrong track you're going to just be
reinforcing bad principles Paul Marino
will talk about this more and and RJ
post rito as well let's go to a second
audience question ma'am hi my name is
Linda and I'm originally from Honduras
and I'm Virginian by choice and my
question to you dr. Bob is in your
opinion what causes the changes through
time in the perception of these innate
and inalienable rights I'm sorry and the
permanent and consistency of human
nature because I see what's going on
right now and there are so many people
that don't think like us that don't even
you know go back to the founding fathers
much less all you know that you've
talked about thank you well I think you
know it's remember after 9/11 all the
signs that said united we stand the
question is really what do we stand
united on what's going to allow us to be
permanently one people and not divided
into blue and red states and I think
that this is where these principles
really come into play because it's not
so much that you have to buy in if
you're of a particular political
persuasion or that you're a member of a
particular party or that you're even a
member of a particular religion or a
particular denomination right what's
really important is whether or not these
principles are true I think it's come to
a place now in American civic education
and I see this having worked in in
schools across the country trying to
revive these principles that a lot of
people think that this kind of an appeal
to principles and old-fashioned ideas is
simply an appeal to them because they're
old right they're traditional that's not
a good enough reason right a lot of
people raised this objection I think
it's a very good
and has to be handled upfront the
founders talked a lot about equality
they held slaves most of the signers of
the Declaration of Independence
two-thirds of them held slaves how could
that be possible well we spend in our
courses at Hillsdale and the programs
that we run for teachers and in programs
that we offer to citizens at large
a lot of time grappling with that
question for we can certainly understand
how a group of people would say of one
thing it is wrong it is absolutely wrong
and we're going to give the rationale
for its ultimate demise but we're still
going to continue to do it that's an
antenna me a kind of a contradiction
that we can understand however difficult
it is to countenance it the statue for
Martin Luther King's memorial on the
mall has just had ground broken form on
that it will emblazon a quotation he had
about the Declaration of Independence
that that was a promissory note right
that it was something that was not just
a promise though but it was a principle
established it was not a principle that
the founders in Bennett they're saying
we are articulating this principle this
has been true for all times what we are
doing is basing a regime a form of
government on that particular principle
so I think when you talk to your friends
and neighbors about these principles
don't say well they're right just
because a bunch of dead white guys
believed it right the question is
whether they're true today whether they
have always been true or not what's the
best explanation for government what's
the best foundation for government you
know I think we we so often we've become
so used to government solving so much
that we think that it's going to be able
to get us out of any quagmire any
problem any challenge we have come to
believe that in an era in which the
president will take somebody's name down
and say that one of his aides will get
on the problem that he or she is having
right that kind of direct
kradic action we have come to a place
where independent action self-government
is increasingly difficult so I think to
rest away from the administrative state
that that mentality is going to take a
long time but it can be as something as
simple as just getting together with a
group of your fellow citizens and
reading through some of the documents
take up a short opinion editorial like
Madison's property and then write into
your own newspapers hope that goes a
little ways towards answered answering
your very good question by the way for
the rest of the story about the American
Founding and and slavery I'd highly
recommend to you a book by Tom West
called vindicating the founders there's
also some excellent information on Matt
Spaulding's website and also on the
Kirby Center's website you can find
links to those things on the Hillsdale
dot edu web pages we'll go to now we
have time for an audience question go
ahead sir good morning my name is Howard
Wooldridge my question concerns privacy
and property rights
besides my good name my most precious
possession is my body and for about a
hundred years now there been a group of
Americans who have wanted to take away
my possession of my body and make it
more of the government's body as opposed
to my own in and every day I know my
colleagues are going to go into
thousands and thousands of homes and
cars looking for certain substances
these prohibited drugs we have today for
those of us who would like to see a
return to precious property rights and
more privacy rights do you think that
those individuals should seek perhaps a
federal law which would strengthen a
Tenth Amendment or perhaps go more to
the state and either you revise their
constitutions or have some type of
legislation which would again
they say strengthen the privacy right so
that the agents of the government would
have a much much tougher time coming
into my home
because it's the the state is thinking
I'm doing something you might hurt
myself as Jefferson said I believe
better the problems involved with too
much Liberty as opposed to too little
it's a question that raises a lot of
different things but one of them and
this is something that the founders
certainly grappled with a lot and that
is how do you make sure that Liberty
doesn't degenerate into license right
you don't have the right to do anything
you want and in fact the founders don't
believe that you have the right to do
anything you want even in the confines
of your own home right so then the
question comes what's the Prudential
line right how do we define and and and
define rights and duties and I think
that the Tenth Amendment is a thing that
has been much neglected the ninth
amendment as well the Bill of Rights we
often look to as the sort of main source
of our rights but in fact it's not at
all just the Bill of Rights the Bill of
Rights is basically a structural thing
it says to the federal government you
shall not do this and you shall not do
that it is a restriction on their powers
and their authority the structure of the
Constitution is the main thing it's an
edifice that's what we teach in our
Constitution course it's really an
architecture of Liberty right Jefferson
called it an empire of Reason it's an
it's it's a really important question
and I think that without getting into
all of the different issues that one
would have to raise with search and
seizure or questions of drug
legalization or even those sort of
things I think I'll just start make this
one note that for the founders virtue
was a very important thing you know when
you look to the the question of
individual and the community you have to
realize that actions that a single
individual takes have ramifications for
the community at large no man is an
island unto himself or herself for the
founders local government was very
important and you know at the time of
the founding there were a lot of very
strict laws about what you could or
could not even say what you could or
could not way
including what you could or could not do
in terms of actions so I think that it's
not clear at all that the founders would
have been for example in favor of the
decriminalization of drugs it's a debate
that certainly can be can be had but
there's something about the fact that we
as a people have to perpetuate a
republic and you know for the founders
this goes back to the idea of human
nature
we're a combination of things right we
have reason and we have passions and
those things calm reason and roiling
passions are always in conflict we see
that a lot when we're working with
students right the whole purpose of
growing up is to allow the passions to
be controlled more and more by your
reason think of that on a grand cosmic
scale when you think of a nation of 300
million people how do we govern
ourselves how do we keep a republic
going if we let Liberty degenerate into
license
that's why virtue really does matter you
know the Great Seal of the United States
has at the base of it and this goes to
the the uniquenesses of the American
Founding the Great Seal of the United
States has it's at its base nois Ordo
seclorum new order of the ages the
United States really was something new
in the first seven iterations of that
Great Seal the single word that was
there was virtue and choosing to have no
asaro seclorum they were not discarding
the idea of virtue it's written
throughout the correspondence throughout
the documents you can look to the
Virginia Constitution in the
Massachusetts Constitution and it says
that without certain virtues and it
names them without a recurrence to
certain fundamental principles we will
not survive and when you're looking to
public officials you better see those
certain virtues as well
right now the Virginia and Massachusetts
constitutions were the models for a lot
of others including the United States
Constitution we have time for one more
question and then we'll wrap up this
session sir Frank from force Virginia in
order to implement these principles and
concepts that you're discussing with us
today I have a question if a politician
ran for national office openly rejecting
FDR's second Bill of Rights listing them
and embracing the original Bill of
Rights do you believe he or she is
electable absolutely
there's 33,000 people here today right
there's a lot of people for whom the
Constitution is not seen as just an
advisory document and you know it's it's
an interesting thing
I've lived in Washington now just for
for three years and before living there
I was in Michigan and lived in some
other so-called blue areas and you hear
the term inside the beltway and you
really don't know kind of what that
mentality is in a way until you sort of
live it and you realize that the pulling
out of the pocket copy of the
Constitution is a political affectation
for so many they don't know it they
don't really care what's in there it's
an advisory document it's a thing of
technical detail right and it's not the
the clauses of the Constitution are very
important but we shouldn't get hung up
on only questions of that kind of
technicality that they're very important
I don't mean to minimize the fact that
for example when we have a piece of
healthcare legislation I think it does
make sense to say it should be justified
by the document right a Justice of the
Supreme Court ah in the state of
Michigan told me that he had been
canvassing various people on this very
question and he said asking one person
so what what's the the justification for
the particular pieces of legislation
that are under consideration now the
response was the Health Clause there
there isn't a Health Clause
right what you have to do is begin to
make politicians accountable in both
parties what is the constitutional
rationale can you explain that can you
without reference to notes and by the
way this is a teleprompter free townhall
can you without reference to notes
explain what's in the Constitution
because this is the fundamental issue
every one of those elected officials
takes an oath and that oath us of the
Constitution and what we have now is far
too much of a kind of technocratic
regime and this holds true I might fear
for for both and indeed a lot of other
smaller parties even that purport to
have an understanding of the
Constitution you have to think about the
whole thing and those principles broadly
speaking